we fought with swords
now I touch on my last moments I
received a deadly hurt from the Viper a
serpent inhabits the hole of my heart
soon shall my son's black their swords
in the blood of Ella they wax red with
fury they burn with rage
those gallant youths will not rest till
they have avenged their father we fought
with swords battle fifty and one have
been fought under my banners from my
early youth I learned to dye my sword in
crimson I never yet could find a king
more valiant than myself the gods now
invite me to them death is not to be
lamented tis with joy I cease the
goddesses of destiny are come to fetch
me
Odin has sent them from the habitation
of the gods I shall be joyfully received
into the highest seat I shall Quaffle
goblets among the gods the hours of my
life are passed away I laugh as I die
[Music]
thus the most glorious conqueror
declined to the piteous lot of a
prisoner a lesson that no man should put
too much trust in fortune
[Music]
I've heard of this disasters he happened
to be looking on the game's nevertheless
he kept an unmoved countenance and in no
way broke down not only did he dissemble
his grief and conceal the news of his
father's death but he did not even allow
a clamor to arise and forbade the
panic-stricken people to leave the scene
of the sports
thus loath to interrupt the spectacle by
ceasing the games he neither clouded his
countenance nor turned his eyes from
public merriment to dwell upon his
private to sorrow for he would not fall
suddenly into the deepest melancholy
from the height of festal joy or seem to
behave more like an afflicted son than a
blithe captain
but when seawood heard the same tidings
he loved his father more than he cared
for his own pain and in his distraction
plunged deeply into his foot the spear
he chanced to be holding dead to all
bodily troubles in his stony sadness for
he wished to hurt some part of his body
severely that he might more patiently
bear the wound in his soul by this act
he showed at once his bravery and grief
and bore his lot like a son who's both
afflicted and steadfast but beyond
received the tidings of his father's
death whilst he was playing a dice and
squeezed so violently the peace that he
was grasping that he wrung the blood
from his fingers and shed it on the
table
whereon he said that assuredly the cast
of fate was more fickle than that of the
very die which he was throwing when Ella
heard this he judged that the father's
death had been born with the toughest
and most stubborn spirit by that son of
the three who had paid no filial respect
to his deceased and therefore he dreaded
the bravery of Eva most but Eva went
towards England and when he saw that his
fleet was not strong enough to join
battle with the enemy he chose to be
cunning rather than bow
old and tried a shrewd trick on Ella
begging as a pledge of peace between
them a strip of land as great as he
could cover with a horse's hide he
gained his request for the king suppose
that it would cost little and thought
himself happy that so strong a man
begged for so little boon instead of a
great one supposing that a tiny skin
would cover but a very little land but
IVA cut the hide out and lengthened it
into various lender thongs
thus enclosing a piece of ground large
enough to build a city on then Ella came
to repent of his lavishness and hardly
said two reckoning the size of the hide
measuring the little skin more narrowly
now that it was cut up than when it was
whole for that which he had thought
would encompass a little strip of ground
he saw lying wide over a great estate
I've are brought into the city when he
founded it supplies that would serve
amply for a siege wishing the defenses
to be as good against scarcity as
against an enemy meanwhile see warden
Bjorn came up with a fleet of 400 ships
and with open challenge declared war
against the king this they did at the
appointed time and when they had
captured him they ordered the figure of
an eagle to be cut into his back
rejoicing to crush their most ruthless
foe by marking him with the cruelest of
birds not satisfied with imprinting a
wound on him they sorted the mangled
flesh thus Ella was done to death and
Bjorn and Seewald went back to their own
kingdoms Ivar governed England for two
years
meanwhile the Danes were stubborn in
revolt and made war and delivered the
sovereignty publicly to a certain Sea
Ward and to Eric both of the Royal line
the sons of Ragnar together with
of 1700 ships attacked them at Schleswig
and destroyed them in a conflict which
lasted six months barrows remain to tell
the tale
the sound on which the war was conducted
has gained equal glory by the death of
Seward and now the Royal stock was
almost extinguished saving only the sons
of Ragnar
[Music]
you